welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and with the Last of Us season
finale having aired oh baby do I want to
talk ethics and morality regarding
Joel's final decision now ethics is a
very vast subject and today we're just
talking Basics because you didn't pay
the 50k annual tuition to attend
Professor vanson's ethics class instead
it's more like you slid a bag of Doritos
across my desk and asked how much you
could get for it and the answer is this
video so since we have been presented
with one of television and video games
biggest ethical dilemmas of all time
let's examine the question did Joel do
the right thing this is gonna get spicy
a quick reminder before we begin to
check out nerdriot.shop where you can
pick up our The Last of Us inspired
t-shirt look for the light support the
channel and check out all of our latest
and greatest merch options over at
nerdride.shop now there are a couple of
important things I want to preface up
top number one I'm going to be talking
about The Last of Us show today so there
are some things that are exclusive to
the show that I'm going to be mentioning
there are some things exclusive to the
game that I'm not going to be mentioning
so that's the deal number two is that
whenever this conversation happens the
skepticism of if the procedure would
work or if if a cure is scientifically
possible inevitably comes up however I
think this just Waters down the
philosophical debate the ethical
question I'm interested in exploring is
if Joel made the right decision to save
Ellie over saving Humanity so for all
intents and purposes for today's video
Let's just assume that had the procedure
happened a cure would have been
developed it's a much more interesting
conversation and with that let's dive
into the morality
foreign
just to set up the scene and to serve as
a reminder to those who might not have
seen it in a while Ellie has an immunity
to cordyceps that the head doctor of the
fireflies believes can be used to
develop a cure for the cordyceps
infection however the procedure would
kill Ellie in the process Ellie is
unconscious on being prepped for surgery
and before she went under she remembers
being with the fireflies but that's all
she remembers and we learned from
Marlene that she was never informed of
the procedure or the possibility of her
dying Joel upon learning that the
procedure would kill her makes his way
to the operation room killing several
guards on the way shoots the doctor
takes Ellie and starts to make his way
out Marlene stops him trying to reason
that it's what Ellie would have wanted
and he shoots and kills her before
driving off in a nearby vehicle so was
this the morally right thing to do let's
look at some ethical theories and see
what we can parse out so there are three
main umbrella types of ethical theories
deontology consequentialism and virtue
ethics the biggest difference between
the first two is that one focuses on the
consequences of the ACT to determine if
it's morally right or wrong and the
other focuses on the act itself each of
these have subcategories but let's look
at them one at a time deontological
ethics believes that an act is right or
wrong depending on the act itself and if
it fits into certain principles duties
or rules Dion comes from the Greek word
that means Duty and while it considers
consequences it first and foremost
considers that the act itself Falls
within one's duty or obligation it's
also absolute in that it theorizes that
some acts are just wrong regardless of
how much happiness it brings to any
amount of people one of the main ethical
theories that branches off of deontology
comes from Emmanuel Kant who believed in
categorical imperatives or moral laws
that one must follow regardless of one's
desires or extenuating circumstances for
example one moral law might be that is
wrong to murder an innocent person so it
doesn't matter if killing a particular
person would result in a greater
happiness for more people you shouldn't
do it because killing an innocent person
is wrong no matter what now I might have
set off some alarms for some people in
relation to Ellie's case Joel stopped an
innocent person from getting killed
would continuism say he made the morally
right choice well no because remember
that continuism and deontology are
absolute no murder means no murder so
all those innocent people Joel killed in
the hallways leading up up to saving
Ellie only innocent people he killed in
general no bueno and Neil druckman and
Craig Mason have stressed again and
again that they want every death to mean
something these aren't faceless NPCs
Jewels killing they're people with lives
and friends and families of their own
it's why the camera lingers on a dead
body for longer than normal it's to
humanize the person whose life was just
taken from them so under deontology and
kantianism Joel did the morally wrong
thing watching something you love is
self-care feels good right well with
geology you can have that good feeling
of self-care in your daily routine too
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in men's health Esquire and
ask men grooming Awards with over 6 000
5 Star reviews just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and GLG will
create a simple and effective skin care
or hair care routine customized just for
you with ingredients that are
dermatologist tested proven to work and
personalized for your needs for Hair
Care geology's got strengthening shampoo
and conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best care of your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products so you wash
your hair less and save money they also
offer body washes and deodorants that
are free of harsh ingredients and smell
great for skincare they have you covered
from all angles fine acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging their
daily personalized skincare routine
comes with two face washes morning face
cream retinol night cream and eye cream
and right now for a limited time you can
get a five piece trial set for only
fifteen dollars if you use the code
rockstar70 at checkout that's over 50 a
product for just fifteen dollars on top
of that you'll get an additional bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair and body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started just click the link in the
description so then let's look at
consequentialism consequentialism as the
name suggests determines if an act is
right or wrong based on if it has good
or bad consequences an example of how
consequence sequentialism values the
consequences of an act over the act
itself is telling a lie to save
someone's life many people would agree
that the act of lying is wrong but if
the consequence of telling a lie is
saving someone's life then under
consequentialism lying would be the
morally right thing to do one of the
biggest ethical theories that falls
under this umbrella is utilitarianism
utilitarianism says that we must choose
the action that brings the greatest good
to the greatest number of people good in
most cases being happiness
utilitarianism is other regarding and
says that as far as morality goes you
are no more special than anyone else
your happiness means the same as someone
else's happiness and sometimes you have
to sacrifice your own happiness for the
greater good his alarms ringing again
yes a utilitarian would say that Joel
should sacrifice his own happiness I.E
Ellie because it would provide the
greatest happiness for the greatest
number of people and that by killing all
of those people and saving one person
over Humanity as a whole Joel has made
the wrong choice so we move on to the
third main ethical Theory virtue ethics
virtue ethics aims to answer the
question what kind of person do I want
to be it is by far the most vague and
personal Theory as it gives no clear
guidelines apart from act as a virtuous
person would act given the situation and
since the definition of a virtuous
person is subjective it's difficult to
apply from an outsider's perspective but
I think we can safely say the exemplary
virtuous person probably wouldn't have
made as many murdery decisions as Joel
did so to sum up these three main
ethical theories it's pretty common to
use Batman as an example and pose the
question should Batman kill the Joker if
Batman was a deontologist which happens
to be the case here he shouldn't kill
the Joker because killing people is
wrong if Batman was a consequentialist
he should kill the Joker because it
would ensure that the Joker won't kill
anyone else ever again and if Batman
subscribed to Virtue ethics he would
have to ask himself if he wanted to be
the type of person who kills people you
may send some saltiness I have over how
big this one is and that's because I'm
salty over how vague it is but if Jill's
decision doesn't fall under
utilitarianism kantianism or virtue
ethics what ethical Theory does his
choice fall under my answer is actually
a different branch of consequentialism
egoism specifically ethical egoism under
ethical egoism one should act to produce
the highest likelihood of long-term
happiness for oneself ethical egoism
states that the promotion of One's Own
good is in accordance with morality and
that one Auto perform an action if and
only if performing that action maximizes
one's self-interest now this might
ruffle some feathers because as someone
looking in we can see non-self-centered
reasons why Joel might make his decision
a lack of consent on Ellie's end being a
huge one I know that would certainly be
one of my biggest concerns regarding the
whole situation but to be honest I don't
think that the lack of consent was
Joel's driving Factor after all he
didn't hold everything up until she was
able to come to and give consent he
immediately took it upon himself to
decide it wasn't going to happen why I
think a big reason is because deep down
he knew Ellie probably would have
consented notice how when Marlene asks
him what he thinks Ellie would decide
and tells him she thinks Ellie would
want to do what's right and he knows it
he can't respond and in the car he lies
to Ellie not only hiding the possible
procedure from her but telling her that
they've stopped looking for a cure her
he doesn't tell her about the procedure
because he's terrified she might choose
to turn around and go back Ellie is the
type of person who would want her death
to mean something and Joel deciding that
she doesn't get to die then strips her
death of its meaning and heroicism
instead of her death potentially saving
Humanity she will likely die like anyone
else by the hands of infected or Raiders
or of old age if Joel was doing this for
Ellie he wouldn't have killed Marlene
who Ellie clearly cared enough about to
ask if she was okay he killed Marlene
out of paranoia and fear that she could
one day take Ellie from him again if
Joel was doing this for Ellie he would
have taken to heart her saying that
after all they had been through and a
very important addition after everything
she had done it can't be for nothing
that there was no halfway with this if
Joel was really doing this for Ellie and
thought that she would be a hundred
percent on board with his game plan he
wouldn't have said I'm sorry Joel wasn't
doing it for Ellie he was doing it for
him he has no interest in saving the
world he wants to save his world when it
all boils down it is a self-serving act
that he makes in his own best interest
but if all ethical theories point to him
making the wrong choice and his
motivations are selfish in nature why do
so many people think he did the right
thing there are a few reasons one of
them being we can recognize the
fireflies moral flaws too in this
scenario Marlene and the fireplace are
largely utilitarian however biomedical
ethics are deontological in nature which
creates a big moral conflict and there
are four principles of biomedical ethics
that are known as the cornerstones of
Ethics in healthcare practice the
biggest one they broke is respect for
autonomy commonly known as informed
consent in which patients should be
presented with the medical situation
options expected outcomes and risks and
have the freedom to make their own
decisions the lack of consent regardless
of if Joel takes it into consideration
tends to rub us the wrong way another
reason many people don't neatly agree
with any of the ethical principles is
because morality is complicated
especially in practice it's not just
critical analysis it's mixed with
emotion it changes as we age and it's
often driven by our gut reaction an over
logical reasoning there are flaws and
criticism regarding every ethical Theory
and in general people tend to mix and
match parts of each to make their
decisions and this leads to
inconsistencies all over the place here
I'll prove it so many people know the
famous trolley problem in short you're
on a trolley whose brakes have just
failed there are five people in the
track ahead who will be killed if the
trolley continues forward however
there's also a track off to the right
with one person on it and there's a
lever in front of you that you can pull
to make the trolley go down that track
instead the question is do you let the
trolley continue straight and kill five
people or do you pull the lever and go
to the right killing one person this is
kind of a one-way Street here I'll just
let you know that not everyone but most
people choose to pull the lever the most
common reason being that killing five
people is worse than killing one person
however let's make a slight Amendment
same situation brakes failed on a
trolley and five people are on the track
but this time you're standing on a
bridge over the tracks and next to you
and this is wild but it's how the
problem goes next to you is a large man
who you're sure that if you push him off
the bridge would be hit by the trolley
and bring it to a stop saving the five
people do you push this man off the
bridge and kill him but save the five
people interesting enough many people
who previously said they would pull the
lever wouldn't push the man in both
scenarios you are actively doing
something to kill one innocent person
and save five one final scenario you are
a transplant surgeon there are five
patients in critical condition all
needing immediate transplants one needs
a kidney one needs a heart when he
deliver one needs a lung and one needs a
pancreas the problem is they all have
the same rare blood type and you know
that there are no matches on the
transplant list but you remember that a
perfectly healthy patient with the same
blood type has come in for a checkup and
is taking a nap in the Next Room over
while waiting to see a doctor you could
kill them and use their organs to save
the five other patients lives should you
do it maybe unsurprisingly the
overwhelming answer to this one is
usually no you shouldn't kill that
person and harvest their organs mostly
because we don't want to live in a
society where it's kosher to harvest
innocent people's organs but it's
interesting how a lot of people's
answers can change throughout these
problems when oftentimes the root of the
ethical dilemma is extremely similar and
that last problem actually Echoes the
scenario we're dealing with in the show
pretty well and in the case we just
looked at the majority of people don't
believe an innocent person should be
killed to save others fascinating as I
said morality is more complicated than
concrete ethical theories and rules and
it's so often led by our gut reaction
that doesn't necessarily mean our gut
reaction is bad but it's important to
look at what drives it and the strongest
thing that makes people understand and
potentially agree with Joel's decision
is empathy of course real life parents
empathize with the parental love that
Joel feels and the willingness to do
anything for that love and when they
were having people play test the game
and give feedback the player was
apparent 100 of the time they agreed
with Joel's decision now that doesn't
mean that acting out of love is
necessarily right love can make people
do bad things and in fact an overarching
theme to this show is that love is
inherently dangerous and yet it is
instinctual and one of the most powerful
driving forces that many people can
empathize with but this isn't the only
level in which we can empathize with
Joel even though Joel is never portrayed
to be a perfect person and in fact is
more of an anti-hero we still empathize
with him because we've been with him for
the entire Journey we see the extreme
loss that he's gone through that causes
the trauma That clouds his judgment we
understand his inability to accept
losing another daughter figure because
we've seen him lost in the darkness and
we have seen him find his light we
recognize that if he's attempted to end
his own life after losing Sarah if there
is no more Ellie then that will likely
be the end for Joel too and that is a
heartbreaking thought and what's more
like Joel we've grown attached to Ellie
throughout this journey and feel a sense
of love and protectiveness towards her
it's easier to want to save this
character that we feel close to as
opposed to a faceless many that we can't
humanize and that's actually a fact
humans are unable to fully grasp the
scope of something once it reaches a
certain magnitude psychic numbing refers
to the phenomenon that as the number of
victims in a tragedy increases our
empathy our willingness to help reliably
decreases individuals appeal more to our
sins of empathy than large groups and
and this is the case with these two
characters who we've spent the whole
season with the show has been setting up
Joel's decision from the beginning
giving us the breadcrumbs that
ultimately lead to his choice Bill
finding someone that he literally can't
and won't live without Henry putting the
Kansas City Rebels lives at risk to save
Sam and Kathleen asking in disbelief if
he really thinks one kid is worth
everything Tommy choosing to stop
putting himself in Danger's way to live
a stable life with his new family in
each of these scenarios we empathize
with the characters they're focused
around and understand why they make the
choices they do and so it follows that
we understand and empathize on an
emotional level with Joel's decision as
well so now I've given you both sides of
the argument and at this point you might
be like okay but which side is right and
the answer is neither side is right and
neither side is wrong because it's not
about right and wrong it's about the
discussion and that is the goal of the
last of us is to spark a conversation
you're meant to have conflicting
feelings it's a conflicting situation
and what a beautiful piece of art to be
able to bring this conversation into the
table and make people think without
telling the audience it's right or wrong
and that's what this video was meant to
achieve too I hope it made you think and
I hope it Sparks discussion and I hope
you'll voice your thoughts on the
situation in the comments that being
said this conversation rightfully evokes
a lot of emotions in people so please
respect that and keep the conversation
civilized and because we're examining
the show here please avoid spoiling the
second game for people until season two
has passed since the second season of
the show will be based on the second
game but I do welcome your input in the
comments let's celebrate the moving
storytelling the first season conveyed
by continuing the discussion an eagerly
awaits season two until then you can
follow me on Twitter at atanavanston and
follow And subscribe to new rockstars
add new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love now if you'll excuse
me I'll take my payment and leave
foreign
[Music]